bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa dj ed oggi stiamo su
daverio organize tiff ragazzi devo
spiegarvi che cazzo è sta roba allora
non ho mai giocato a giochi del genere
cioè però soltanto che questo doveva
assolutamente farlo perché c'è adesso vi
spiego per la mente consiste nell'andare
a rubare delle cose in una casa e la
cosa è veramente stupida perché devi
farlo in una maniera che vedete allora
adesso siamo partiti un attimo che ti
faccio vedere praticamente siamo in
questa casa non si sa come cazzo siamo
entrati ma ci siamo e dobbiamo rubare
delle cose tipo questo telefono in hd
altri ragazzi un telefono fisso senza
cavo non si sa come funzioni ma funziona
va beh devo rubare allora devo rubare
delle cose guardando anche noi siamo dei
vari organizzatissimi ce ne siamo
scritte qui alla fine deve rubare una tv
dove cazzo me la metto non lo so ma devo
rubare una tv cosa che non va bè tutta
sta roba all'altra da un attimo che la
tv l'ho trovata ok non si sa ragazzo noi
da lì dove se ne metta ste cose non
voglio saperlo però un attivo non è che
la trasporti proprio in tasca ecco
comunque ho buttato giù il pendolo
fantastico e comunque nega o dio che ci
attaccano i bastardi ci attacca gli
invasi no vabbè comunque dicevo nel caso
noi non dobbiamo farci scoprire in
teoria no
ecco nel caso ci fosse qualcuno che si
spunta all'improvviso io ho un pendolo
siamo in cucina qui c'è il frigo poi
vedere se c'è la maione noto vedove
antella bastardi
dov'erano tarditi sfondo il frigo brutto
stronzo dove la nutella
distrutto tutto quanto va bene ho
trovato a un attimo una chiave perfetto
la chiave mi servirà qualcosa non so
cosa sono contro le lavatrici devo ok io
veramente non so quando il tizio rientra
in casa che casino si trova ma non
voglio non voglio saperlo è bellissimo
quadro tra l'altro fantastico
ragazzi qualcuno sta aprendo la porta
non so chi ok ok c'è un tizio a
buongiorno io non ho buttato giulio il
pendolo ti giuro cazzo ok se si trova
ragazzi c'è il se quel tizio trova il
pendolo sottosopra son cazzi miei
ragazzi è un piano fermin attimo un
piano devo andare di sotto trovato un
tablet intanto fatto anche questo c'è il
contatore della corrente se io stacco i
cavi dovrebbe spegnersi la corrente in
casa problema che se quel tizio mi vede
son cazzi
quindi io direi di stare prima fisso per
vedere se riesco a derubare quello che
posso e poi e poi scende di sotto stacco
tutto devo riuscire a farcela ragazzi un
pò un casino ma ce la posso fare qua
lupo tv tutto se è una scatola di
gioielli un cellulare una barra d'oro
come cazzo faccio a trovare una barra
d'oro spiegate melo è il cos'è sta roba
qui a scatola dei gioielli perfetto
siamo a me ne mancano il 3 devo andare
di soft casertano con la cassaforte ci
hanno assisto non si ok ragazzi non ho
idea di come cazzo funzioni sta roba
quindi devo andare di sotto spegne la
corrente è nato il tizio questo si trova
il frigo che blocca tutto cioè non hai
detto è buongiorno io io non ho buttato
giu niente qui o si sta inglobando il
frigo oppure sia accorto che qualcosa
non va devo cercare di passargli dietro
senza che lui se ne accorga tipo ok
forse spegnere la luce arrestato al
massimo ma è merda aiuto dove dove dov'è
andato domandato ho perso ma [ __ ] ok
ok non ti ho visto anche cosa fa mista
mi sta menando malissimo via ragazzi dai
chiodi chiudi carie aiuto ragazzi devo
spegnere tutto non spegne tutto ok ok
filo rosso filo blu
qualcosa ok beattle cos'è il
proprietario che ha scoperto ma
[ __ ]
beh ragazzi stavolta serio ci sono ma è
così ci sono ragazzi stavolta ti rubo
tutto in casa poi esco e vado pure in
quella dei pizzini [ __ ] devo
aspettare un attimo stavolta ci sono
carichissimo cosa dobbiamo fare
l'album di foto che cazzo me ne faccio
di un'alba non importa poi la radio
chitarra portatile televisione
ovviamente la televisione non si sa dove
ce la mettiamo ma non importa ragazzi
volete delle uova insegno in attivo come
si fa prima si mette la padella sulla
padella poi dopo di che si prende il
tostapane lo si mette proprio sopra e
poi col microonde schiacciate tutto come
si deve
un bicchierino e tutto maggio ma se ti
puoi entrare il tizio e poi li lascio
cadere il quadro in testa no infatti mi
sa che era una possibilità magari tipo
inciampa e muore non si sa perché va
bene speriamo gli si devono rubare tutto
spetta alla chitarra mi pare di sì
perfetto anche questa non sappiamo dove
ce la mettiamo così come il lettore dvd
cazzo sto arrivando perfetto c'è una
lampada o una l'ump firmin attimo ok
cazzo non hanno preso dovevo prenderlo
prima merda che la luce non funziona
quindi avrà capito subito che c'è
qualcosa che non va
kick ass oddio no no no no no no no dopo
un vaso o un vaso o un vaso lurido falso
[ __ ] ragazzi non è possibile non ha
senso mi ami ha ricacciato indietro la
lampada ma come cazzo si fa ma
[ __ ] la se adesso ruba senza
neanche sapere che cazzo deve rubare c'è
michael di non me ne frega una minchia
vai col dvd la camera non assenza mi ha
ricacciato indietro lampada allora
cellulare devono rubare alla questa
volta questa volta ci riesco me ne frega
un cazzo mai così il quadro buttate
passi [ __ ] solo merita manco fosse
casa sua questo stronzo che si permette
di lanciarmi la roba poiché non ho idea
di cosa sia ragazzi ceramente questo
l'oblo piglio perfetto che a voi da
altri ragazzi la chiave varia sempre non
è sempre nello stesso posto quindi non
un'idea di dove cazzo si adesso spero al
cesso perché sono
no noi da perfetto dalla veniamo qui
questo le mazzette le mazzette in bagno
qualcuno me lo deve spiegare comunque
perché ancora non lo capite
mi manca niente praticamente finito
credo che l'ala lingotto d'oro sia qui
dentro non lo so sto presentimento qui e
cosa cazzo cos'è 2829 ok perfetto devo
prendere 28 29 credo sia la password di
sto coso credo non lo so 829
sì sì madonna mia che ladro a chi è
lupin iii con dame e panco lo sono un
fenomeno allora lingotto d'oro ce
l'avevano capito che cazzo è però non
importa dovrebbe essere risolto prima
che quel tizio arrivi ragazzi dobbiamo
correre tipo in frettissima no no allora
lo scazzo no no no no ok ok ok forse non
sono accorto forse non se n'è accorto
ok che incalza ma chi cazzo è lo slider
man mio dio max non corre porca [ __ ]
questo è un jumper chiudi chiudi gioca
sul cartone l armadio nell'armadio ok ok
siamo salvi al massimo apre la porta e
faccio tipo google settete lurido
stronzo pezzo di merda non meno a me non
mi avrai che cazzo fa sembra un picchio
lo chiudo ha detto no cazzola dovevo
chiudo sarebbe stato troppo epico
chiudono dentro l'armadio cazzo a piedi
sotto non c'è un cazzo controllato
ovunque più spiega qualcuno mi spiega
dove ma non è che ce l'ha in tasca quel
tizio o poi su ci sono uscito come sono
uscito ragazzi ma no dove trovare altre
due cose ma [ __ ] ragazzi ci provo
l'ultima volta perché sono uscito e non
ho rubato tutto volevo rubare tutto
quanto interiore perché voglio voglio
dimostrare di essere un ladro modello
faccio un ultimo tentativo ragazzi
perché voglio rubare voglio rubare tu
dove diavolo la trova la chiave per la
chitarra è praticamente finito mi
mancano due cose devo trovare solo sta
cazzo di chiave dove è la chiave non è
quella che a ok la scatola di gioia i
ragazzi mi manca solo la chiave solo una
[ __ ] chiave poi ci sono tre cazzo
l'onesto quel bastardo dove cazzo è e
non lo so sì sì ok
l'ho trovato a domandare di sopra
togliti frigo
sì ci sono mi sono prima caridi suo
prima che arrivi su 67 88 ok 6 7 8 fermi
fermi fermi 6 7 8 6
ok ok ok ok ho tutto io l'ho soltanto
uscire stolido entrato bastardo come
cazzo faccio usciremo che cazzo ma non è
da
ma qualcuno no no no la porta ma molto
nullo giorno all'alba [ __ ] si sono
fatta mio dio 38.000 dollari e per una
[ __ ] pianto stavo perdendo tutto il
bottino se il prossimo vita lo faccio il
coc con loop end perché a sto punto
sticazzi phone che ragazzi vi invitano
se non mi piace per le mutande di sto
tizio che saranno pieni di televisori
chitarre orologi a pendolo e tutto
quello che ho rubato è quindi secondo me
lo meritano anche ragazzi se vi dove
piaciuto come al solito è stato un
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook come noi video trovato nella
descrizione essere riscritti iscrivetevi
non ci rivediamo il prossimo video bei
ragazzi